on a appris que c'était des défis dans
la classe et enfin dans l'établissement
l'a dernièrement on a su christopher
devait faire une fellation non mais là
c'est pas possible qu'ils ne soient pas
poursuivis pour sa folle épreuve mais
malheureusement les jeunes comment vous
l'avez nous voir voilà on vient nous
voir donc c'est des témoignages voilà
mais ils ne veulent pas témoigner parce
qu'ils ont des pressions ils ont peur de
témoigner et c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut changer quoi on en apprend de plus
en plus on a
on a créé un groupe de parents par ange
de d'enfants qui n'ont ni fin à leurs
jours et une 19e victime depuis le vol a
envie de venir mais là c'est vraiment
les parents de il ya 3 4 ans et
le témoignage qu'on a vu dans votre
émission
hier soir
c'est un crève coeur pour nous aussi
parce qu'on on
je pense que je parle c'est que vous
avez témoignés sandrine je sais que vous
avez témoignés ici justement pour que ça
se reproduise plus voilà et aujourd'hui
vous voyez le témoignage hier et vous
vous dites en plus c'est ce que vous
savez que c'est ce qu'on disait hier
avec avec l'amant de dina et son frère
ont dit que dina effet et c'est vraiment
s'est fait tout ce qu'il fallait puisque
elle était au courant dès le début elle
a été voir les professeurs elle a été
voir la cpe et c'est vrai qu'on se dit
c'est pas possible c'était si c'est pas
possible on arrive à une telle issue
ça vous a fait mal hier de voir sous
témoigne louis c'est ce que je disais je
parle là en tant que parents qui n'ont
pas pu venir avec moi ce soir c'est un
crève coeur de d'entendre ça on a
l'impression de revivre le le suicide de
notre propre enfant
on regarde ce témoignage et on se dit
basse et c'est christopher c'est pauline
haas et yolan cema elle s'est tous ces
jeunes qui sont partis et et ça continue
ça continue encore et encore jusqu'à ce
qu'un jour enfin emma va vraiment
falloir faire quelque chose parce que on
peut pas nous parents
qui ont qui ont eu cette perte d'un
enfant on peut plus supporter ça c'est
pas possible faut vraiment que ça
s'arrête quand il y en a vraiment marre
je sais pas ce que vous allez pouvoir
nous dire mais
vous avez vous avez monté une
association wim harcèlement est
exactement aujourd'hui c'est que la
question que je pose à chaque fois parce
qu'il est offert est parti en 2017 vous
avez d'autres enfants oui trois autres
trois enfants quand vous faites toute la
famille pour vous reconstruire pour est
ce que vous y pensez tous les jours est
ce que votre vie bien sûr n'est plus la
même depuis non depuis ce jour d'avril
2010 est on y pense tous les jours ça
brise une famille c'est sûr que ma fille
a été obligé de partir du jour au
lendemain de la maison puisqu'elle a
retrouvé son propre frère à l'âge de 18
ans
ça brise une famille tout entière parce
qu'on ne comprend pas
nous on en parle régulièrement les
proches préfèrent
concèze
ça pose beaucoup de problèmes dans tous
les sens du terme